how old are you now i'm 27 i'm gonna be
28 in a couple days what's your
background you you were in high school
and then you didn't go to college did
you yeah and then like i i got someone
gave me this troll doll for like
graduation somewhere good luck in
college it's some stupid present you
know it's like a troll down with the
trauma yeah it like has a diploma and a
crap i was like this thank you thank you
very much i was couldn't wait to throw
it out as soon as i turned around and
then i just kept it in my bedroom you
know and then my mom heard about this
impression contest and so i said oh
maybe i'll i'll do it and uh and so i
did these troll doll like different
celebrities auditioning for these troll
doll commercials so you you see so your
thing was impressions completely i
wanted to be on saturday live it's the
only reason i did stand up your whole
your whole goal was i'll put together a
couple of minutes
do it for lorne michaels yeah and then
i'll audition and i'll get on saturday
night live but the i used to do like the
church lady and things that like would
make sense like why why would you need
two churches who needs you yeah okay
yeah it's worthless i'm thinking like
lauren was gonna call him you know jimmy
dana's sick
i know there's a lot of talent in
socrates new york could you come down
please and i was like so i i was like
dude the church they're not going to do
it the whole thing i was an idiot you
know when you used my bedroom when you
were doing impressions for lauren like
do you remember what you auditioned yeah
yeah i did i did you know what i did and
i was happy i did this because they said
to me they said to my uh manager we
don't want to see the troll though we
saw the troll bit yeah all right it's
probably the only thing he does yeah
yeah so i did a celebrity walk-a-thon
how'd that go and i just and i didn't i
didn't say who i was doing right so i
just said like i was like uh okay people
okay we're walking why don't we just
take a bus it could be a boss-a-thon
come on you know
i did uh
did you always have a knack for this
it's something that you know what it was
it's like yeah i always i was into it i
was always into doing voices and like
it's like you know when you go see rocky
that's the way my best analogy i think
you go see rocking at the end of the
movie you feel like working out and you
feel like fighting somebody yeah yeah
it's like that it's like i feel i feel
like i can do that voice after i watch
something like that that's a good jerry
seinfeld though i mean because a lot of
people do jerry and so you when you
audition for lauren you get what five
minutes i think it was like seven
minutes to be exact did other guys
audition with you that actually made it
were you in in a situation where a bunch
of you guys got in or were you the only
guy that year who got in horatio sans
and chris parnell got in as well were
you nervous well completely not only
that because out of my way out they go
sorry jimmy sorry to bother you but this
guy has to go ahead of you guys another
audition
come here allen and this guy allen walks
by with a keyboard and wigs a box full
of wigs i go i'm screwed
so so
after you did the audition did you think
you'd never get the job or did you think
could did lauren laugh by the way yeah
you know what i did i ended up doing
adam sandler oh in the audition and i
remember him laughing so i was like i
was like yeah my mom uh wants me to go
on this walkathon and i keep telling her
you know shout out
how cool is this story like even if i
don't get this i can tell my friends
like i made laura michaels laugh like
doing so many different angles of cool
it was like a wonder years moment you
know i was like you hear joni mitchell
in the back and yeah paul never talked
again
so everything was leading up to just
this one audition man i would have
crapped my pants you know it is i don't
know why for this one odd moment i
wasn't nervous